the supreme court is set to decide any
day now if the obama-era daca program
will be allowed to stand
daca protects more than 600 000
undocumented immigrants
brought to the united states as children
protects them from being deported
as jan crawford reports many so-called
dreamers are waiting to learn their fate
while they help protect americans from
the coronavirus
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
as the kovid 19 pandemic continues to
spread
a key group is on the front lines
recipients of daca
it's really hard to plan when
you're on a constant expiration date all
20 years of my education including my
medical degree
would just become useless overnight more
than 200
000 are working in essential jobs and
nearly 30
000 are employed in the health care
system like daniel and donna a 27 year
old licensed practical nurse who came
from mexico when he was one
he's now conducting covet 19 testing in
new mexico
you can see maybe there's a line of cars
it's me and four co-workers that are
doing this
health care worker fabiola dominguez a
mother of three
also came from mexico when she was six i
work as a pediatric icu nurse
due to cover 19 i had to transition into
adult
icu as the supreme court prepares to
issue its ruling
janet napolitano head of homeland
security department in the obama
administration
defends the measure in reality the daca
program
does not change any existing law and
because
it is lawful the administration's
attempt to rescind it was done
improperly
but former pennsylvania immigration
judge andrew arthur says there are
strong
arguments that daca is illegal the issue
in this case is who gets to make the
immigration laws the elected
representatives of the people in
congress
or the unelected secretary of homeland
security and that's the principle that
the trump administration is fighting for
in this case
daca activist jose munoz says if the
court
sides with the trump administration they
will continue the fight
i have confidence in the power of
organizers to really like fight and move
things forward but it's important to
recognize that
it's hard
now a recent cbs news poll shows that a
majority of americans
in both parties overwhelmingly support
daca the question now of course
is what the supreme court may decide and
whether this entire issue ends up back
in the hands of congress
during an election year tony
all right jan thank you very much